I have recently been called far left by
the polyamorous cuban-american streamer
Stephen Kenneth Destiny benell gorinson
II
um in all seriousness polyamorous Cuban
American these are jokes Destiny's a
friend of mine but a bunch of people
sent me a clip during which the streamer
Destiny is I guess talking about the
space now for those who aren't aware of
how streaming content works most of
what's on the screen is a video game of
some kind I I can't tell if this is
Grand Theft Auto or Tetris or what it is
and then in the bottom right corner
that's the guy who we're going to hear
from Destiny talking here's what he had
to say let's listen and then we will
discuss
like The Young Turks and David Pacman
but these guys are like progressives
they're like yeah logical Spectrum I
would say that like Stephen Crowder is
pretty far right but the daily wire
Stephen Carter's further to the right
than the dealer but the daily wire
represents a solid center-right
conservative mouthpiece center-right
conservative establishment uh not
establishment I'm sorry center right
conservative alternative media is the
daily wire there is nothing like the
closest thing that would be Center left
my guess would be based on a little bit
of her like pod save America or
something but like otherwise like
alternative left media space like
everybody else is way to loved The Young
Turks is not Center left they are far
left David Pacman is barely Center left
but more far left you can't say The
Young Turks are Center left whoa
so all right there's some interesting
stuff here now the real story here and
this goes back to Mike why am I talking
about this I'm talking about it because
it's funny but also I'm talking about it
because I had this conversation when I
was on Lex Friedman a few weeks ago I
guess it's been almost a month it's
crazy
um we had this conversation about where
is the left on the political spectrum
and the difference is like I'm to Joe
Biden's left and but you know I'm
certainly to the right of socialists the
way socialists are normally placed on
the political Spectrum although I might
take issue with that the real story in
hearing Stephen Kenneth Destiny benel II
say this is that Destiny and I agree on
almost everything so it's hard to
imagine an analysis in which I'm far
left and Destiny is not fall left far
left call it what you want like either
neither of us is far left or we're both
far left and I I don't know if Destiny's
being provocative or you know whatever
the case may be I'm a progressive Social
Democrat advocating for some way to get
everybody health care although I'm
flexible on exactly how we do it a
living wage campaign Finance reform we
need Environmental Protections we need
to use progressive taxation to reduce
inequality and fund social program these
are not number one these aren't radical
or Fringe ideas these are mainstream
ideas popular among most Americans if
they are fairly polled and the default
sort of northern European social
democracy so to say that that's far left
doesn't seem super accurate it is also
true that as opposed to some on the
so-called far left
I'm not a dogmatic ideologue where I
blindly follow a party line or get
involved in tribal identity and that
makes me like Destiny I think he also
doesn't do that I've been critical of
the democratic party I've been critical
of the Progressive Movement I've been
critical of corporate media when it is
appropriate like destiny I also
regularly engage with people from
different parts of the political
Spectrum different backgrounds I've done
the Joe Rogan show twice did Lex
Friedman I was on the Patrick Bet David
podcast the Trump supporter Etc
what you also have to understand is that
there's a movement in the U.S the right
wing that calls what I just described
far left I think that they're wrong
there is a movement in the U.S and
globally socialists that call My Views
Center left I put myself between Center
left and far left because we're sort of
forced into this political Spectrum but
the most important the funniest thing
about all of this is that Destiny's
views and My Views line up almost
exactly on most issues as far as I know
he supports many of the same policies I
do he once praised me as a left-wing
commentator who's reasonable and
intellectually honest so if I'm far left
I think Destiny is also far left now I
will say one other thing and this is
speculation okay and I'll talk to
Destiny anytime he can't I guess go on
my twitch streams because he's banned on
Twitch and it's a whole mess but I'd
love to talk about this
Destiny might label me as far left
because he may be going through a period
of distancing himself from the
progressive wing of the left and he may
want to appeal to a more Centrist
audience I don't know if that's the case
I'm speculating I also think that
there's a false equivalence between even
comparing the daily wire to the David
packman show because the daily wire is a
right-wing propaganda Outlet
that is out there to spread
disinformation and to fear monger
on a daily basis and they are funded by
millionaire donors who have a vested
interest in maintaining the status quo
and undermining democracy the David
Pacman show is actually an independent
media platform without any of these
millionaire donors certainly we have
people who have a membership who happen
to be millionaires but we don't have
millionaire donors funding Us in the way
that the daily wire does and there's
really no way to even talk about the
daily wire in the David packman show in
the same sentence or on the same
Spectrum although he may just have been
talking about political alignment rather
than what the media Outlets represent so
to sum this up you know if if I'm far
left Destiny's far left it's either both
of us or neither of us and I thought it
was thought it was an interesting
comment one of our sponsors today is Bon
charge I have always enjoyed dry saunas
you get in there your heart rate is up
dilates the blood vessels can soothe
achy joints and muscles it's relaxing
it's just a great way to remove a little
stress BonChon large is the creator of
the infrared sauna blanket which you can
enjoy from home super easy to set up
heats up fast you don't have to have
your head inside like at a traditional
sauna at the gym nice for meditating or
reading getting work done relaxing I
have found it to be a great way to
unwind at the end of a long day easy to
clean Sleek lightweight design easy to
store and comes with a 12-month warranty
and of course if you don't love it
returns are super easy but I think you
will love it and you'll get 15 off when
you go to boncharge.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below